the work that I sell for the most part
is meant primarily for looking at
nonetheless many of our clients may our
biggest clients that auction are
interior designers or interior designer
/ architects who are both buying
furniture for their clients to use to
put into the media room but also serving
as curators of their clients lifestyle
and of their clients taste so a I mean
one of the if you were to say what's a
best seller in my world well best
sellers a nakashima coffee table because
here is this gorgeous slab of wood the
soul of the tree as nakashima famously
said that was created in the 60s or the
70s and it was you know made by
nakashima and and and the men and women
that worked in his studio and if you
were a doctor or lawyer and Princeton
New Jersey you drove out there you
bought the coffee table from him and a
year later it was delivered to you you
got sketches of it he helped you he
helped pick out the piece with you if
you if you look at that well today's
collector is still using the coffee
table in the same way as the first owner
is so when that piece that was you know
is sold by the original owner with me at
auction the person buying it is more
than likely putting it in their living
room in front of their sofa just like
that original client New Jersey did and
so it is going to be used and they are
going to put you know coffee table books
on it and do things like that but
there's still a lot of what I sell today
that is more about standalone kind of
sculptural
you